so what are everyone's most memorable
birthdays i'll start with you nathan
my most memorable birthday uh oh god
start with somebody else please please
okay anybody right off the bat my
favorite birthday was when i turned 30
and uh my grandmother had recently
passed and i heard this word wow i'm
really going deep i heard this word i'd
never heard before hyperion and i was
like i'm gonna look this up and hyperion
is one of the tallest redwood trees and
for that birthday i found it but you
have to like geo-locate it and it's not
on a trail and so i was like wading
through this river totally clear you can
see all the way to the stones like
carrying my sack over my bag what kind
of movie are you living in right now
what a good one that's amazing
and
are you that kind of person you're
always like adventurous like that yeah
who doesn't love redwood trees i love i
am a nerd
i love them
okay now you have to one-up redwoods
eric what's your favorite birthday it's
on my 27th birthday i planted a redwood
tree
and um
[Laughter]
i like that
what did you do you've had enough time
sir yes i forgot all about it
i had gone nearly a decade without
having a party i had forgotten and
someone said it's time you have to have
you have to have a party it's kind of
stressful it can be yes yes yes but i
had someone say i'll take care of all
the arrangement and i rented a
restaurant yeah i had like 350 people
there okay
barbra streisand showed up
who also has my birthday we're both
april 24th don't worry about it happy
birthday
happy birthday byra you and i we're just
birthday sisters there's so much in
common um that's amazing why is she
randomly her wonderful husband came and
played my father on castle i don't know
if you remember that do i remember
[Applause]
i love that your dad ended up being like
that was so amazing
[Music]
you